250 WHO CLAIM THEM.
EXPEDIA SAYS THEY SYMBOLIZE
ASSURANCE TO TELL PEOPLE THEY
CAN GET BACK OUT THERE AND FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
JOE JONAS, NO PROMISE, NO HAND
JOKES, WE HAD A LOT FLYING
AROUND IN THE MEETING.
I'M GOING TO LEAVE THAT UP TO
YOU.
>> YOU GOT ME LAUGHING ALREADY,
THIS EARLY, I LOVE IT.
>> I SAID, JOE JONAS HAS GOT A
GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR.
YOU DO.
REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU, WE'RE
HAPPY YOU'RE HERE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
> TAKE US TO THE ROOM, TALK TO
THE HAND, JOE, WAS THIS YOUR
IDEA?
THEIR IDEA, DID YOU SAY, I'VE
GOT A GOOD IDEA -- IT'S MY HAND!
>> I THINK IT WAS A BIT OF A
COLLABORATION, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, WHO YOU TRAVEL WITH IS SO
IMPORTANT.
FOR ME, IT'S USUALLY EITHER WITH
MY BROTHERS, FAMILY FRIENDS OR
I'M GOING TO SEE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
AND THE WAY I THINK OF IT, IT
CAN SOMETIMES BE A LITTLE SCARY
TO GET BACK OUT THERE NOW IN A
SAFE WAY FOR ALL OF US.
AND IF I CAN BE SOME SORT OF
LENDING SUPPORT AND BE THE
HELPING HAND FOR YOU, I MEAN, I
HAVE MINE HERE TOO.
MY BLUE EXPEDIA HAND.
>> WELL --
>> -- YEAH, I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THIS.
>> I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A FIGHT IN THE
STUDIO FOR THE HAND.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE STEADY
CAM IS GOING TO GET IT ON CLAUS
OR JARED ON THE GIB.
DO YOU CARE?
>> WHATEVER HAND FITS BEST.
HOW'S THAT SOUND?
>> IT IS A BIG HAND.
LISTEN, YOU'VE BEEN QUARANTINING
WITH YOU AND YOUR BROTHERS.
AND YOU WERE ON THE ROADS WITH
"HAPPINESS BEGINS."
DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO GET BACK ON
THE ROAD?
THAT ALBUM "COOL" WAS SO GOOD?
>> THANK YOU.
>> ARE YOU READY TO GET BACK ON
THE ROAD?
>> I'M READY TO GET BACK ON THE
ROAD.
THIS YEAR, IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING
IN DIFFERENT WAYS WHAT I'VE
MISSED IS GETTING ON STAGE AND
SEEING THE FANS AND FACES.
THE MINUTE THAT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN
IN A SAFE WAY, I'M THERE.
I HOPE YOU'RE THERE, GAYLE.
>> LISTEN, YOU CAN COUNT ON ME,
I LOVE THE SHOW.
LISTEN, YOU'VE BEEN QUARANTINING
WITH AT LEAST TWO OF YOUR
FAVORITE PEOPLE, YOUR FAVORITE
WIFE, SOPHIE AND YOUR BABY.
>> DEFINITELY.
>> EVERYBODY HAS BABIES, I GET
IT, I DON'T THINK IT'S UNTIL YOU
HAVE YOUR OWN.
PEOPLE WOULD TALK ABOUT THEIR
KIDS MY EYES WOULD GLAZE OVER.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU AS A DAD
WHAT THIS HAS BEEN LIKE FOR YOU?
WHAT HAS SURPRISED YOU?
WHAT IS IT?
>> IT'S BEEN AMAZING.
IT'S BEEN FORCED TIME AT HOME.
YOU KNOW, I'M ALWAYS ON THE GO,
I'M ALWAYS MOVING AND TRAVELING
AND TOURING AND TO BE IN ONE
PLACE FOR A SOLID AMOUNT OF TIME
AND JUST HAVE MY FEET ON THE
GROUND AND BE WITH MY FAMILY, MY
IMMEDIATE FAMILY IS TIME I DON'T
THINK I'LL GET BACK.
SO I'M SO THANKFUL AND GRATEFUL.
>> HOW CUTE IS SHE?
>> GORGEOUS.
>> JOE, ANY INSIGHTS INTO
FATHERHOOD?
ANY LESSONS LEARNED IN YOUR
YEAR-PLUS?
>> YEAH.
>> NAPS ARE NICE.
ALL AROUND.
>> NAPS ARE REALLY NICE.
>> JOE, YOU AND SOPHIE ARE
DEVELOPING A MENTAL HEALTH
FOUNDATION.
WHAT YOU CAN TELL US ABOUT THAT?
WHAT'S YOUR AIM THERE?
>> WELL, FOR US, IT'S ALWAYS AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC AS A COUPLE.
BUT ALSO AS ENTERTAINERS AND FOR
US, WE'VE NOTICED HOW MUCH JUST
IN THE LAST YEAR, YEAR AND A
HALF, IT'S TAKEN A TOLL ON A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
>> HAS IT TAKEN A TOLL ON YOU?
HAS IT TAKEN A TOLL ON YOU?
>> I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
FIND NEW WAYS TO CALM MY MIND
AND CHECK IN WITH MYSELF.
AND MAKE SURE THAT I'M TAKING
CARE OF MYSELF IN DIFFERENT
WAYS.
WHETHER THAT'S THROUGH
MEDITATION OR SPEAKING TO A
THERAPIST, EVEN THOSE THINGS
THAT, FOR ME AT LEAST, HAVE GONE
A LONG WAY.
AND ESPECIALLY THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS OUT THERE WHO HAVE PUT
THEIR LIFE ON THE LINE DAILY AND
ARE WORKING THESE EXTREME HOURS.
IT'S REALLY INTENSE.
AND WE ALL HAVE LOVED ONES THAT
ARE OUT THERE DOING THIS.
OR AT LEAST WE KNOW SOMEBODY
THAT'S OUT THERE DOING THIS.
AND SO, WE'RE THINKING OF WAYS,
CREATIVE WAYS THAT WE CAN GIVE
BACK TO THEM.
DONATE OUR TIME, DONATE WHETHER
IT'S MONEY TO REALLY FOCUSING ON
AN AMAZING CHARITY THAT'S GOING
TO GIVE BACK FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
>> JOE, I'M CURIOUS, HAVE YOU
FOUND YOURSELF MORE CREATIVE
DURING QUARANTINE?
>> OH, YEAH, IF YOU'RE LOOKING
TO MY LEFT AND RIGHT, YOU'RE
PRETTY MUCH IN MY STUDIO, AS YOU
CAN SEE.
I'M ALWAYS WRITING AND RECORDING
AND I FIND IT VERY INSPIRING,
AND THE MUSIC, YOU END UP
WRITING CAN BE EVERYTHING FROM
EMOTIONAL THINGS, EMOTIONAL
SONGS ABOUT WHAT YOU WENT
THROUGH PERSONALLY OR WHAT THE
WORLD IS GOING THROUGH.
BUT HOPEFUL SONGS FOR A FIGHTER
FUTURE TO GET OUT THERE AND
TRAVEL AND SPEND OUR TIME DOING
WHAT WE LOVE THE MOST.
>> JOE, WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR HAND.
LET ME TELL YOU, I CAN TELL YOU
GET A PEDICURE ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S BEEN REALLY GOOD.
I'VE BEEN TO THE SPA WITH YOU
GUYS.
I KNOW YOU BELIEVE IN SELF-CARE.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT IDEA,
THE FIRST 250 PEOPLE, CLAUS AND
JARED WILL FIGHT IT OUT HERE.
WE'LL LET YOU KNO